let's get into the first story we got
this link from project veritas
fox 26 houston tv reporter ivory hecker
goes public
i don't need to read it ivory sitting
right here so let's just start from the
beginning
what uh what happened well uh weird
stuff started to happen
late last summer uh they
they the first thing that just really
stunned me was when fox 26
sent me to cover covet treatment at a
hospital they didn't like what the
doctor said
and then they went ahead and punished me
for allowing his son uh his sound bite
to
reach people's eardrums so
so you you you just asked the doctor
some questions
and yeah you got in trouble for what the
person they wanted you to interview said
a medical professional yeah so um yeah
so this was this was two weeks after dr
stella emanuel
spoke in dc saying saying what she said
about hydroxychlorquin
and then i i was sent two weeks later to
talk to a doctor who was treating covet
patient he had actually teamed up with
the army
medical team from the department of
defense they were all treating covet
patients
and the interview was very dull the army
wouldn't tell me anything
i knew that the audience was still
buzzing about
hydroxychloroquine after all of that
crazy news about still emanuel the mass
censorship across social media that we
saw after that
people still people had i think people
had lost more trust than ever
in in media when they saw this strange
blackout
where every hydroxychloroquine post was
being deleted
um still yeah so so even even we have to
be careful otherwise youtube would take
the whole show down
right yeah so sorry i'm saying the h
word i hope i hope your show
surprisingly
i mean look i changed it if it gets
deleted it does
yeah if youtube pulls that and it's that
creepy because we're talking about
censorship in
in the media yeah i mean that's that's
the level of
insanity we're dealing with right now
yeah and we're not telling people what
to do we're not medical professionals so
we want to clarify that
and we're just talking about the facts
of the story which are very important
you talked to a medical professional in
the field
dealing with real life situations and
and could you
could you expand on on on his kind of
take
what was what was it so like why why did
this happen here
this all that happened doll interview
with the army they won't tell me a thing
i know people are buzzing about
hydroxychloroquine so i say
final question of the whole interview i
say by the way did you do you guys
do you guys use hydroxycorquin and then
he said actually
we we have used it and we've had great
success
i know it's very controversial but we
throw the whole kitchen sink at them we
treat we treat them with a lot of
they have a whole recipe of treatments
for covet patients
and uh so i i actually added that as the
final soundbite in my tv package and by
the way guys i just
i the story i'm telling you i literally
just uploaded
uh youtube if you check my social media
uh i
uploaded my boss's own words on this so
you can go
check what my bosses said about this uh
after after
the show youtube.com ivory hecker i
believe
or yeah i mean just search ivory hacker
i guess i don't know if it's
sometimes that doesn't work yeah yeah i
guess yeah and maybe
it doesn't work anyway uh if you go to
my instagram reel.ivery i just uploaded
it there
anyway so uh so the bosses the boss
i added that is the last sound bite of
the package oh by the way he he is using
this this hospital is implementing the
controversial drug
uh and i and i called it controversial i
just left it at that
and uh my minutes before era my bosses
were like get rid of that sound bite we
do not want that in our newscast and i
was like
okay well why is that um they said it
well you didn't
include the context of other drugs
they're using i was like oh okay okay so
i got rid of it from the
tv news it didn't air in the tv news i
uploaded that soundbite to facebook with
the caption having all the drugs he uses
to treat kovit so his whole
his whole recipe is on there and the
bosses
flipped out they flipped out they said
that i
uh was not following their instruction i
did exactly what they told me to do
right
wow so anyway they went so far
as to uh they actually shut down my
social media
they said you're not allowed to post
anything until we say so
and then so i was in like a week-long
blackout
and then they said okay you can post on
social media but only
things that we approve which is safe
news wow
and but then uh they but they instituted
basically a permanent social uh social
uh a permanent ban
on coverage of coveted drug treatment so
i was no longer
allowed to cover covet drug treatments
because i
could not comprehend the narrative the
narrative was
the president was talking about this
right and here's the thing
this i'm i'm adding zero commentary zero
opinion
opinion to this just here's his sound
bite this is what he said
yahoo news had a story about you know
hcq
and they had a story titled drug
endorsed by trump
no more effective than placebo at
warding off coronavirus
studies suggest a couple days ago they
had another article by yahoo news i'm
not saying this yahoo news is saying
this
studies shows hydroxychloroquine and
zinc treatments increased coronavirus
survival rate by almost three times
that's yahoo news but to be fair i mean
it's a year apart yeah
so there was some there were some
studies a lot that would
have been retracted and i think the i
think here's the fascinating thing
though
that doctor i interviewed he was adding
the zinc with the hydroxyl
apparently people are saying that it
works more effectively if there's zinc
mixed with it
and there's other previous studies
without zinc uh and
and that's why dr chris martinson of
peak prosperity was talking about how
there was a debunked study that that
was personally not adding up to the
science that that he questioned
that came out about hydroxychloride so
let's let's just say this right now
do not take any advice like you
seriously got to go talk to a doctor you
do not get it from us
just because there's some yahoo stories
that say one thing or another doesn't
mean you should do anything
you should talk to a doctor and take
your doctor's advice i think the biggest
thing
i think one of the things youtube is
concerned about one of the things is
that you get these stories about this
lady eating fish food or whatever and
they don't want to get smeared in the
media
having supported shows that have
promoted or talked about it at all so
we're not we
want to be very clear our focus is on
the media's response to this
exactly you go and talk to a doctor
before you do anything so
looking at the comparison of those two
studies almost a year apart
it's just it's more of a confirmation
that we need to keep the conversation
going out in the public stop shutting
down conversation about this because
we could have we could have maybe
connected more dots on this a lot
earlier
well i will add that that study that's
come out is not peer-reviewed
and it's it's a it's a preliminary
research study that is not to be used
for guidelines according to it's like
the first paragraph in the study says do
not use this for clinic for you know in
clinical use
it is not peer-reviewed so i think this
is one of the things that we have to be
careful about and
for whatever reason youtube freaks out
now i will say
the creepier aspect of it is you can't
even you can't even ask a doctor
right right it was a doctor who was
doing but here's here's
one thing that just stopped me in my
tracks a couple of weeks ago
i was i was thinking back to that doctor
and thinking over this
this crazy journey these past like 10
months or whatever it's been
and i googled him and i came across
some something that said that his
death rate was dramatically lower in his
hospital than other hospitals and i was
like
what and i looked into this further and
i actually made calls myself and
and collected raw data and
came to find that he has dramatically
lower death rates
at his hospital compared to other
hospitals across
the county the nation and the world
this is a major story and i think this
is why youtube has had
the hammer on it so effectively because
you know there's a lot of implications
here i don't want to jump to conclusions
i'm not going to jump to conclusions but
people should do their own research do
their own homework the medical studies
are out there you could read them
yourselves
some are debunked but but the
conversations that are being had
are having to be had outside of big
social media companies and that's sad
and also outside of corporate news
outlets as well i will i will add there
is a really
creepy like i don't i don't you describe
it but
there's the left the establishment left
has their creepy blue and on world view
where rachel maddow screams russia for
years and they'll just believe it
and then you do have you know q and on
people and people who just
outright believe certain things and this
is the challenge
um people going online and just reading
whatever and assuming it's true that's
why i'm like look a lot
we've mentioned this before i've had
people say that they don't trust their
own doctor and i'm like if you don't
trust
your own local doctor like who do you
trust like what do you do you know what
i mean like
what's your response to go ask your
neighbor agatha or something like i'm
sorry i couldn't do that
i have to talk to a doctor maybe get a
second opinion you should have a
relationship with them you should get
some of the scientific studies send them
to your medical professional and have an
honest real discussion with them because
if you can't trust your doctor
you're at the wrong doctor you should be
having real honest conversations but i
gotta stress this point i turn on the tv
every day
and you'll see like some woman with
blonde pigtails prancing through the
fields and it'll be like
she's happy because she takes flubbodon
is flabbo done right for you
and i'm like they just promote they
don't even tell me what the drug does
yeah
i remember seeing a commercial i'm not
going to name the drug they'll come
after me these people are litigious
but it was like sure i'll keep it vague
and it was asking if this drug is right
for you and i'm just like you didn't
even tell me what it does
yeah so it's like some some old man's
going to call and he's going to be like
i saw a commercial is it right for me
and they're like sir this is for
pregnant women
well the commercial didn't tell me that
but but these commercials that
youtube is probably taking ad money from
oh tv news is definitely taking ad money
from that and any tv news viewer knows
that
the commercial breaks are full of drug
companies okay
tv news is heavily funded by drug
companies
and does that compromise the news cast
when the coverage turns comes to drugs i
don't know but
but here's the thing guys so i when i
found out those
those death rates at the hospital it
really
uh you know made me stop in my tracks
and say let me circle back to that story
they banned me from last year
so that's what i've been digging on the
past few weeks i'm going to release an
independent report on this in
in the coming days uh unveiling uh
you know really digging deep into the
banned
information about about what's really
happening in these hospitals what what
this guy's doing
and he he's not just just using one he
actually faced hydroxychloroquine out
because he
got too much pressure on him the
pressure was intense he was using a
recipe of
almost almost 10 different items that
were really key he says
it's a very interesting story i'm going
to talk to uh
quite a few people for this report and i
hope you guys enjoy it i know some
medical doctors too that i could connect
you with uh and also
another thing i wanted to add i love
hearing the side effects for those
commercials
yeah like like it's a jillion yeah yeah
and it's like
what the hell that's a majority of the
commercial spaces so so
but i wanna uh going back to like the
corporate side of this
they i guess what they were saying was
that in in this video that came out that
uh
when you the video you got for project
veritas you had one
uh higher up saying that about bitcoin
that certain you know ethnic minorities
wouldn't be interested in stories so
they don't report it
and so i'm wondering in this regard if
what is the reason why a corporate
executive would say
don't tell this story it sounds like the
answer is they want to make money
right yeah i really i really
am not entirely sure what the motive was
at the top i think i think fox at this
time
and i'm talking fox corp they they feel
such a target on their back for having
the name fox
and they are really you're really
watching fox start to crumble to that
pressure
is what's happening is they're starting
to be so careful
and if they see other media censoring
something out they join that team and
say
we'll be safer yeah oh yeah
yeah so uh what i found interesting in
the in the the video that you did
or that you released was when the that
one woman
says you know she passed on a story
about bitcoin because the 5 pm
hour is like largely you know black
people who wouldn't be interested in the
story
things like that and you mentioned that
they were really like targeting
demographics and trying to figure out
what your news would cater to them
yes could you explain that to us oh yeah
it's in in
news it's like everything's broken down
into these little demographics and
actually
the it's like a large
amount of the behind-the-scenes
conversation in news is about racial
groups
well what's this racial group doing
what's that racial group doing and how
will this racial group respond
to this news or whatever and it it's
it's crazy it's uh it's it's all through
race colored lenses opposite of what mlk
had in mind by the way
but uh so yeah they they she just made
an assumption that
that uh if you're poor and black you
don't care about
bitcoin maybe it's because they haven't
been told about bitcoin because
these news outlets just say they
wouldn't care anyway
they make an assumption about a person
based on their race when they could be
wrong
maybe if you gave information to people
an opportunity to understand they might
actually care about it
right and if you look at one technology
that has enriched people has
helped people has taken people out of
poverty
and given them some wealth what
technology recently has allowed people
to do that
cryptocurrencies and bitcoin they have
helped so many developing countries
third world countries there have been so
many charity efforts there have been so
many amazing things happening in the
bitcoin cryptocurrency space that help
people that it's just it's just kind of
crazy to see
someone's perception controlling uh you
know the reporting
on something that is so crucially
important uh like bitcoin
it it feels to me like there's
i guess it's a hive mind it's the
collective i refer to group think
yeah right so there is this major media
hive
and if you step out of line they all
point at you in the same direction and
they fire their
figurative you know uh lasers at you
all of a sudden now you're getting the
heat from every single media outlet
every single activist organization
and then everyone gets scared it'll come
for them so they shut off working with
you you get cancelled
i wonder if that's what we're seeing
with like you mentioned the pressure at
these news stations
yeah fox doesn't want to get canceled by
by
being being said to be touting
a drug that is said to not work so
they're just gonna
they're they're gonna ban coverage of
the drug to protect themselves
i actually have experience with this so
when i worked for
fusion which was the abc news univision
joint venture
i was talking to the president of the
company and he told me
you know our job here is to side with
the audience that's what he called it
what it basically meant was we make news
you know content that caters to a group
of people that is
looking for that confirmation bias i
asked him i was like so
are you saying to me that if there is a
factual news story
but it would be offensive to our
audience we don't report it and he said
i think that's fair yes that i think
summarizes it
that is the state of the american media
that happened to me almost six years ago
okay so this is yours this is your story
yeah yeah yeah
oh my gosh i was i was basically trying
to quit for the past 10 months but i had
this crazy rigid fox contract
that's exactly what happened to me
what's your okay i had a two-year
contract with fusion
and after about a year i'll i'll start
from the beginning so
you know i worked at vice i got
contacted by this recruitment company
they said here's what we want to do we
basically we love what you've done with
vice news because i was that was the
founding member i was the first person
they hired and
really shaped a lot of it they said we
want you to do that exact same thing
here with new technology new methodology
and
and i was like that's fantastic went and
talked they gave me some numbers i said
this is fantastic i'm gonna have
a budget i'm gonna have a team i'm gonna
be making great money and we're gonna
launch something really incredible
within about six months or so the
company went from we want to be
edgy and youthful to we are completely
woke in every way and
we outright hate white people i'm not
kidding the editor-in-chief changed his
twitter banner to say down with
whiteness
and it was a black fist like revolution
fest
and so that to me was like okay i
i just go on the ground and i tell
people what's happening
i'm not here to claim a race is bad or
to push ideology and so i started uh
having these conversations where i'd be
just i'd just say like hey i'm not
comfortable with the content
shift and eventually it became more
golden handcuffs for me
they didn't want this kind of content
anymore they wanted activists
progressive
and this is how the conversation came
about one of the first was
i said look if if uh you know was when i
was
i go to his office and i said i see
what's going on at this company i
don't agree with your ideology it
doesn't fit like my style of reporting
i just want to do on the ground you know
documentaries
i went to a weapons expo in in brazil we
went we looked at guns and missiles and
there were generals walking around and
stuff
nothing overtly ideological and so
when i when i when i come back and i see
what they're doing with all the content
i'm like this stuff is laughable
i mean like you're you're dumping what
hundreds of millions of dollars into
being to make an activist blog
but people do this work for free you
don't need to start a newsroom to make
an activist blog go
start a non-profit do you want to
actually do news and want to make a
successful company this isn't going to
work
that's where that conversation comes
from where he says look we're just here
to side with the audience a nice
and then i said what audience is that he
says look young people are progressive
this is the thing that they want
and i said i don't think it's about what
they want i think it's about
giving fair and honest information so
that they can understand what's
happening in the world
and then he said look you know we're
here to just side with the audience
that's when i said
does that mean if there's a factual news
story that would be offensive to them we
wouldn't report he said yes i think
that's fair
i had a meeting with them in i think
this was in california because
that we were based in miami and i sat
down with them after about
a year or so into the contract and i
said if this is the way things are going
to go
clearly i shouldn't be here so how about
we just end it now and you guys sever my
contract
but they didn't want to do that i think
they were worried that i was one of
their high profile hires they called it
the expendables they hired a bunch of
prominent personalities from across new
york media
they were like what would happen if the
news comes out tim will breaks contract
and quits they don't want to deal with
the bad pr
so he was like yo i i see what you're
saying i'm really sorry
we'll we'll figure it out the president
outright told me that the company was
racist
like straight up to the company was
racist and it was and it was you know
there were issues
and so he said we'll talk about it later
well what ended up happening later was i
got a phone call
and i thought this was it i got an email
they're like we need to have a
conversation with you and i was like
finally it's been a few months
now they're going to end my contract
early and i can be be rid of this this
you know this company
no i get a phone call thinking the guy's
gonna say we've you know considered what
you've talked about and we're gonna let
you go instead he said
i just wanted to let you know um we have
a very serious uh
matter to discuss with you and and and i
think um
i'd rather just tell you in person and i
was like wonderful and he goes yes
we're going to be depositing a very
large bonus should be around 40 000
into your bank account and we don't want
you to be alarmed by the number and i
went
what yeah yeah everyone's getting a
bonus and i started laughing
and i was like is this a joke i i don't
even know why i got a bonus
i was not part of whatever the structure
is they were trying to build and then i
look at my bank and i'm like
okay and then i just waited i suppose
and
had more and more the same conversations
they didn't want this kind of coverage
anymore
i can understand it when they want to
start the company they wanted to make
vice
after they changed their
course they realized they had me under a
contract and they didn't want to look
bad
so then come august of 2016 the same
thing happens we should call
and i'm like here it is my contract is
up thank you for everything you've done
for the company at this time we will not
be renewing your contract and i said
thank you and have a nice day
and that was it that was done that's
when i started my own youtube thing
that's corruption yeah they their their
goal was not to provide information to
people to help them better their lives
their explicit goal their expressed goal
was to give confirmation bias
to people now i know the left will look
at my content and say tim you rag on
democrats all day and night blah blah
yeah that's a fair point i mean i
personally as a pundit and commentator
do
i have my biases i rag on republicans in
a different way and not nearly as much
as i do the democrats
but we're gonna do something very very
different with our newsroom we're gonna
get an independent fact checker
two or three and they're gonna be in a
different office outside of our newsroom
fact-checking the articles we write
because we're gonna do it properly
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you wanna see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you